ja und da habe ich mich aufgeregt über
markus söder den markus söder geht jetzt
zunehmend hier zumindest in berlin als
der heilsbringer derjenige also der die
union stadt armin laschet in die jamaika
koalition führen kann nach dem motto we
going to jamaica habe diese spekulation
soll natürlich zeigen wir eine
ausgezehrte unionstruppen jetzt nach
armin laschet doch noch an die macht
kommt denn einig sind sich die auguren
jedes armin laschet dass das nämlich
wahrscheinlich nicht nichts mehr wird
die frage ist nur wer sagt sie wer sagt
ihnen diese drei worte denn dann sind es
wirklich 3
ich hoffe wenn ich lautet wer dann söder
oder vielleicht doch der
ministerpräsident von sachsen ein mann
der neuen generation oder dangel günther
der mann aus schleswig holstein der mit
robert habeck die grünen-chefs so
erfolgreich eine schwarz-gelb-grüne
koalition
gebildeten und gebildet hat da oben die
immer noch hält also aber es würde allen
voran denn es geht darum natürlich
denjenigen zu finden jetzt auch im
kreuzer diese koalition durchzusetzen
wie jamaika koalition und das ist nach
meinung vieler kein anderer als markus
röth doch bevor der nach deutschland
nach berlin geht den geht bayern
sicherlich vor das ist meine feste
überzeugung deswegen halte ich diese
konditionen auch für völlig falsch und
markus söder würde sicher nicht nicht
mit robert habeck gemeinsam beschließen
dass die windräder die er nun für bayern
auf 2000 meter abstand gebracht hat
künftig wieder vor der haustür eines
jeden einzelnen stehen könnten nein erst
bayern dann deutschland silber kann
warten er macht aber erst in vier jahren
vielleicht würde dir da ein bisschen
widersprechen zumindest ich glaube dass
markus söder so viel blut geleckt hat
dass er unbedingt kanzler werden will
und dass er natürlich auch weiß dass in
vier jahren die situation ganz anders
aussehen kann nehmen wir an das käme
einer ampel also armin laschet nicht in
die regierung dann steht da womöglich
ein gestärkter iren sparen als
oppositionsführer oder jemand anders und
warum sollte der sich das dann in vier
jahren von markus söder nochmal
wegnehmen lassen aber unabhängig davon
eine sache die mich
wirklich
aufgeregt hat und mit armin laschet
langsamen auch wirklich leid auf der
einen seite sagen oder gibt es
vergleiche in berlin die vergleichende
simon ist und die immer damals gesagt
hat und was wird aus mir ja also armin
laschet der nicht von der macht kann
aber gleichzeitig dass markus söder
immer so tut als würde anstatt
unterstützen und ihm dann immer die
blutgrätsche jeden tag wieder verpassen
durch attacken durch interviewaussagen
das sozusagen die csu alles hintertreibt
was er dort vor hat in sachen regierung
dann fällig ist wer jetzt mal ehrlich zu
sagen von markus söder ich glaube nicht
daran dass armin laschet der richtige
kanzler wäre für deutschland und es
lassen das hat er ehrlicherweise gesagt
auf die art wie politiker sprechen
nämlich ein bisschen verklausuliert das
hat markus söder vor der wahl gesagt er
selber wollte es werden hat kein zweifel
daran gelassen auch über sein
generalsekretär
bis vor vier tage vor der wahl dass er
markus söder der bessere wer hat kein
zweifel nach der wahl gelassen dass mit
ihm mindestens 30 uhr jetzt hinterher so
als könnte sondieren und er fährt jetzt
nach berlin und tut dann so hat ja über
möglicherweise nur jamaika regierung in
meine meinung kennst du ja zu markus
söder paul ich bin schon langsam leid
ich mal wieder zu sagen weil ich
wirklich sagen markus söder ist mit
schuld wenn ich einer der
hauptschuldigen am wahlergebnis von
armin laschet markus söder ist der judas
der der union und ich meine es jetzt mit
allem respekt ich will nicht mehr
übersehen ausschließt aber wie er das
machen
weil ich entschuldige mich markus söder
wirklich gesprochen ja ich meine nicht
dass ein judas habe ich meine bildlich
gesprochen was da passiert ist man lernt
auch von klein auf sei ein teamplayer
wenn du in der hockey mannschaft spielt
in der fußball mannschaft spielst du
musst ein teamplayer sein markus söder
ist es nicht geworden anstatt sich dann
hinter ihn zu stellen übrigens hier muss
ich eine lanze für robert habeck brechen
alle wissen ich bin kein grün fern aber
wie er das gemacht hat erstmal frau berg
nach vorne dann jetzt am ende ich finde
in der zeit hat er sich viel besser
feiern als markus söder markus söder
alleine wo er mit julian reichen
interview sagt klar würz armin und du
wusstest die der will nicht dass er es
wird dh er hat das bild in der
öffentlichkeit geschafft zu
katapultieren
dass armin laschet den versager ist es
nicht machen sollte und das hat die
union wählerstimmen gekostet wir sehen
will ich glaube ja ich glaube dass die
union wählerstimmen gekostet hat dass
man nicht auf den wähler gehört hat denn
der wähler hat sich ganz klar dafür
ausgesprochen
söder als kanzler einzusetzen die leute
wollten söder und ich kenne wahnsinnig
viele leute aus dem umfeld auch die
gesagt hätten werde derjenige gewesen
welcher dann hätte ich die cdu gewählt
und ich glaube die sind jetzt selber
schuld deshalb nur den ärzten erstmal
schön auch einer der gewesen wäre das
kann ich jetzt kann ich sagen wie die
wähler sich an hätten hätten aber ich
hab selber auch in meinem umfeld und das
hat man ja auch immer wieder gelesen da
schon eine große sympathie philips oder
gesehen und dem man auch sehr viel
zugetraut hat und dass eine partei
sehenden auges tatsächlich in ihren
untergang galoppiert das ist mir
wirklich schleierhaft karl lauterbach
hätte oder scholz gegen markus söder
verloren nein olaf scholz hat auch gegen
markus söder gewonnen die kampagne
hätten wir ein bisschen anders also
gestaltet aber natürlich ist auch markus
söder also extrem angreifbar das ist
keine frage weil also die wolken sind
sie doch eine meinung zum beispiel ein
crooner tatsächlich muss man sagen war
so nicht der schwächste punkt von söder
aber soll da hat sich natürlich in sehr
vieler hinsicht immer wieder
widersprochen hat immer wieder auch so
widersprüchliche aussagen machte gilt
als jemand dem ein bisschen also das
opportunistische anhaftet wo man den
eindruck bekommt dass er die dinge so
präsentiert wie also ist bekommt ja bei
ihnen und der spd nie
vorhersagen also bei olaf scholz haben
die leute schon gespürt was der was ja
auch immer gesagt hat er hat einen plan
wie man es machen muss also leute konnte
das leicht erklären das war ein
attraktiver plan und daher glaube ich
hätte auch sie davon also
ich glaube
programm gewesen ja ich bin markus söder
das überrascht mich sehr dass du das
sagst weil markus söder hat ja gerade in
der korona zeit sehr sehr sehr stark
sicher eingebracht ich weiß gar nicht
wieder deine meinung ist aber er hat
natürlich mit der bundeskanzlerin
zusammen und im jeweiligen spd-vertreter
die die alle pressekonferenzen gemacht
ist nach diesen runden gab und sie auch
sehr sehr stark inhaltlich bestimmt also
er hatte in dieser wichtigen krisenphase
dh dass und das waren ja durchaus
positive werte sicherlich mitgenommen
und noch einiges andere und vielleicht
wäre er dann für viele der attraktivere
partner gewesen für die jamaika
koalition
habe ich nur ein punkt den einsatz die
sich natürlich ein riesen problem weil
er mit den grün überhaupt nicht auf eine
auf eine wellenlänge kommt es gibt in
bayern ein besonderes gesetz nur eine
sache für die abstandsregelung von
windrädern ein windrad muss mindestens
zehnmal mit soweit stehen wie es hoch
ist die meisten windräder in bayern sind
200 meter hoch das heißt die fläche von
windrad zum nächsten haus ist 2000 meter
im durchschnitt im deutschen ist es 1000
meter dh 0,05 prozent der bayerischen
fläche ist für windrad kompatibel das
müsste er natürlich aufheben und hätte
alle bayern auf einmal mit schildern
wahrscheinlich tauschen punkt machen nur
einen punkt hier leiter einsatz
sie haben wollen wir dürfen darauf
einfach zwei siegen gesagt haben naja
balkon aber nicht sein schwächster punkt
ich möchte einzelbeispiel sind immer
blöd aber das steht für mich wirklich
exemplarisch für bayern für markus söder
für corona ein freund von mir damals im
totalen lockt wir haben zusammen gewohnt
in münchen und wir hatten keinen balkon
und keinen garten es war eine kleine
wohnung ich bin direkt nach düsseldorf
konnte ich glücklicherweise weil ich den
lok tor in münchen nicht ertragen habe
und er war aber dann ruft er mich an und
was passiert er saß auf einer bank
draußen weil wir hatten keinen balkon
und keinen garten das war eine kleine
wohnung saß draußen auf der bank alleine
dann kam polizisten gesagt nur sport
machen draußen ist erlaubt er darf nicht
alleine auf einer bank sitzen das heißt
wenn wir immer sagen markus söder das so
toll gemacht während der korona politik
muss ich sagen was da dem kunden von mir
passiert ist das finde ich wirklich
exemplarisch für der staat hat bereits
münchen kann man
nicht reparieren war das ist ja ein
interessantes gedankenspiel in dem sinne
also ich glaube dass söder daran
gescheitert wäre dass er wirklich also
dass das programm ist markus söder und
die zeit ist vorbei ich glaube wirklich
dass diese zeit vorbei ist das also
parteien gewährt werden wenn sie
überzeugende konzepte haben gratis die
leute haben ja eher angst vor dem
klimawandel und die wollen quasi von
einer partei in dieser zeit geleitet
werden wo sie denken also dich da da
wird meine arbeit so da wird meine
zukunft einigermaßen gut abgesichert was
hat olaf scholz genau erklären können ja
gesagt der klimawandel kommt wir müssen
die klima also werden wir schaffen
erneuerbarer energien aber ich mache das
ohne dass euch die mieten durch die
decke gehen ohne dass euch die renten
sinken ich erhöhe sogar noch den
mindestlohn da hat also als sicherheit
ähnlich übrigens wie das damals gemacht
hat sicherheit im wandel ein ähnliches
konzept hat olaf scholz jetzt auch der
wahlkampf ist ja ein bisschen vorbei
erläutert hatte
[Musik]